hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 20 to do so much
we have to talk about this is one of the
best episodes all season and one of the
best episodes for a very certain villain
character that's going to be very
important in the spin-off thankfully a
moment in the end of the episode answer
questions about the timeline just that
there was a lot of confusion as to when
this episode takes place relative to the
arrow finale just careful for spoilers
I'm gonna explain the timeline right now
just because that was like the burning
question on everyone's mind last week so
this episode takes place concurrently
with last week's episode of arrow the
last moment in this episode when Oliver
says I might need a favor from you takes
place before Oliver in mrs. wedding
started so at some point before or
during last week's episode of arrow
Oliver flew to Central City to help out
and then flew back so for the most part
it totally worked out so on the top five
moments here we go so number five the
reverse-flash explains that he's trying
to get something back that was taken
from him the most important quote in
this episode was like right at the
beginning I was so perfect think about
the things that define your life job
family co-workers home imagine if in one
day in a flash it was all taken away
from you what would you do to try and
get it back that's a double-edged sword
because a Bart Thawne is talking about
him getting something back getting the
future back that was taken from him
presumably from the flash that's why I
guess he's mad at the flash but he's
also putting the question to Eddie you
know is Eddie going to do something to
try and get back the future that will be
taken from him his future with Iris
Eddie isn't evil or anything right now
it just there been a lot of interviews
that the actor has done where he talks
about a dramatic shift in the character
he looks like he's definitely souring on
Barry Allen at the end of the episode he
and iris break up if you love me you'll
let this end and she loves him she does
love him so she lets it end that doesn't
mean Eddie's going to turn against team
flash and help the reverse-flash
accomplish his goal but I do think that
they're sowing seeds now that will grow
to be really big things in season 2 it's
like the damian darhk-- quote on arrow
you know laying things down that are
going to be happening next season on to
number four the power accelerator starts
powering back on there's a couple of
things that could be going on here
one wells could be using it as a bargain
chip if the particle accelerator goes
off it causes a ton of damage he's going
to try and extort something from Barry
Allen so that he can change the future
and get back to whatever it was he lost
alternatively he could just be using the
particle accelerator to create an energy
discharge that will help him time travel
like it could just be part of the
equation necessary to get that far into
the future think about it this way Barry
isn't quite as fast as the reverse-flash
he still was able to time-travel but
only a short distance it seems like the
way they're explaining it is is the
further you want the time travel
backwards or forwards the more energy
the more Speed Force you have to expend
Gideon said in episode 17 that the
reverse-flash exhausted all of his Speed
Force you know as if it's like a
quantifiable thing when he traveled back
to try and kill young Barry Allen so the
particle accelerator could just be like
a larger version of the device that was
underneath his wheelchair that was
giving him power I saw a lot of you guys
had questions about reverse-flash Tech
on Twitter especially like the flash
ring you know like how does it work the
way I think about it is is it is like
super far 25th century future tech so
everything is just super miniaturized so
the flash ring works the way it does
just because it's such advanced tech
they could just miniaturize everything
they haven't really explained where the
ring comes from on the show like did a
bard dawn get the reverse flash ring the
same way that he got it in the comics if
memory serves correctly I think he took
it from the flash Museum they've changed
a bar Thon's back story in the comics a
couple times though the most current
version the one that geoff johns road is
just like a little bit different in that
story he got all of his flash gear like
like the suit the ring from a time
capsule although I you know I think in
the context of the show you know more to
the people make their own tech he's a
genius so he might have also made his
ring he has remembered that the show is
taking some liberties with the comics so
look at Eddie here I think he's probably
going to turn into like a hunter zolomon
type character with a Thawne name which
it which is totally different from the
comics on to number three team flash
tries to take the metahumans to LeAnn
you this is so much fun I was so happy
that they gave Leanna you that shoutout
all I could think about was them joining
Captain Boomerang in that underground
prison he's just one more rogue the
captain Colt could add to his roster
this is actually a pretty complex plan
so I could you kind of broke this into a
couple different moments they need a lot
of help to get them out of town so Joe
goes to the DA they had a really
interesting scene together so I'm
wondering if that DA and Joe are going
to have like some sort of relationship
or more scenes together next season it
just it feels like they have a lot of
chemistry on-screen one of the really
important things that shows have to do
as they work into new seasons as develop
more secondary characters expand the
universe
Cisco's truck dampen their powers it was
totally solid
Captain Cold was the one that sabotaged
it though that's why things went south
but I do love the argument that they
have inside there one of the key things
about the flash rogues are is it none of
them really like each other that much
they're really more a partnership of
opportunity it's like hey there's
millions of dollars to be had why don't
we put our differences aside for a
moment and go after this as you can see
some rogues like weather wizard are way
more hot-headed
usually that would be heat waves roll
heatwave is like the craziest rogue
there is we also see death bolt from
arrow which was nice it's nice to see
Doug Jones again he was kind of like the
red shirt of the episode because really
of all the really fun rogues in this
episode the most fun one was Captain
Cold this is seriously like the best
Captain Cold episode hands down one of
the reasons I think that they did it
that way is so they can get you more
pumped up about him being in the
spin-off series
I think his speech - Barry Allen at the
end was much more meaningful than the
reverse-flash of speech but the
reverse-flash of speech at the beginning
about doing whatever it took to get back
what you lost that's more important to
the plot captain Cole was more like hey
I'm a double-crosser don't ever expect
me to not double-cross you he just said
it in the most poetic way possible they
also took the fair share opportunity to
drop a green lantern bomb I thought
they'd shut this place down yeah one of
their test pilots disappeared for those
asking I don't expect to ever see Green
Lantern on the flash or arrow but if he
were to show up somewhere if Hal Jordan
were to show up somewhere it would be on
the flash first onto number two
Barry Allen completely wipes captain
cold from public records this is also a
really important thing setting up the
spin-off series Captain Cold will go
back and forth between the flash and the
spin-off series I mean he'll probably be
featured more on the spin-off series
just because he's a serious regular
there but I knew there was a big
question you know when he was announced
for the spin-off is he going to be
leading the flash no that's not the case
you just probably won't see
as much on the flash the interesting
thing though is that he is not going to
be a villain character on that series I
mean he's still a villainous character
but in the context of the narrative that
we'll be seeing in the spin-off series
he will be part of the hero group rip
hunter is just like you know baking a
superhero disaster team pie and he needs
a few bad eggs to complete the recipe so
you see like heatwave captain cold
working with the atom and his friends I
know that sounds weird but we're going
to get a promo for it after the flash
finale next week so that should explain
at least a few things and finally my
number one WTF moment firestorm and
Oliver Queen crash the party
like I said this moment happened
probably like you know right before or
in the early moments of last week's
episode of arrow in terms of the
timeline so Oliver's getting married
team arrows getting gassed after this
happened did anybody else notice how
much they slowed down some of the
special effects in this like when the
reverse-flash used the ring to put a
suit on they like they slowed time down
so it looked a little bit cooler yet
like a better look at it they did the
same thing with firestorm - that's
usually something they only do when the
special effects look really good or they
want to spend extra money just to make
it look extra mind-blowing I feel like
the special effects have been pretty
good this season you know if you look
way back to the first couple of episodes
you can see they were still trying to
figure it out but it's been almost half
a year they've had a lot of time to
perfect it so I think going into season
2 of the flash as well as the spin-off
and arrow special effects will look a
lot better the easier and the cheaper
they are to do the more you'll see them
so you get more really cool scenes like
this where the flash is chasing the
reverse-flash around town and it pans
out and shows the entire city a couple
of the really fun tidbits in this
Oliver's teeny tiny robots courtesy of
the atom nice callback to that episode
when Ray Palmer used the nanites to fix
his head and the reverse-flash tells him
when he's going to die I think that's
also a subtle reference to the fact that
Oliver will not be using the Lazarus Pit
to live for hundreds and hundreds of
years like racial goal they just want to
hammer home the fact that Oliver is
Oliver Queen he's not like the racial
ghoul character the League of Assassins
character that he's been and because
they did take the reverse-flash down
because they did defeat him I think that
they locked him up and I think that's
what this scene is with him inside one
of the prisons so here's my big question
for you guys you know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think that the reverse-flash
is going to use the particle accelerator
for
why you guys think about that couple
other really fun moments that I wanted
to point out Caitlin snow gaining whammy
by rainbow Raider going apeshit on Cisco
about Ronnie so clearly she has a lot of
deep-seated anger about that still
that's as close to Caitlin snow killer
frost as I'm expecting to get you know
unless we get some sort of flashpoint
paradox moment in the finale
if Barry Allen goes back in time and
saves his mother we could totally get
flashpoint paradox so it would just
dramatically alter all the characters
trajectories in the future then you have
Cisco and golden glider here he actually
gives her her name how come you haven't
given me an awesome name like you give
to everyone else I love the way she
absolutely tortures him in this episode
wouldn't it be hilarious in like a
future season like season 2 season 3 if
it turned out that they just like
totally hooked up on the side and Cisco
didn't tell team flash about it didn't
tell his friends like she starts poking
fun at him for hooking up in the past
and all of a sudden you know Barry and
everyone else inside STAR Labs is like
what what the hell so Cisco you go get a
piece of that don't feel bad about it
you totally deserve it so what I'm going
to do is they're probably going to post
like another promo for the finale I'll
wait I'll do a video for that you know
with like some final predictions for
season 1 and then once the finale airs
next week I'll start doing season 2
videos so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you know there's any
specific bonus videos you guys watch
just leave your requests in the comments
I'm going to be doing flash bonus videos
all summer long there's so much that we
can talk about and we have the spin-off
series legends of tomorrow so it's
happening on Thursday is the CW is
having its up front presentation where
they show advertisers promos and
material for shows that are going to be
airing in the fall so like they'll be
showing off arrow season 4 stuff flash
season 2 stuff and they'll be showing a
promo for legends of tomorrow for the
spin-off series I don't know how much of
that they're going to post online so
whatever ends up happening I'll be doing
videos for that too separately so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to post
you can click here for all my flash
videos and you can click here to catch
up on arrow before the finale tomorrow
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you